Transcription: Aline Besnard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Salut tout le monde !
(Tousse)
Avant de commencer, je dois confesser
que je ne parle pas vraiment français.
J’ai passé dix mois l’année dernière
à apprendre le français
en vivant avec un étudiant appelé Paul
de l’université de Lyon.
Donc si je ressemble
à un Molière des temps modernes,
c’est grâce à Paul et sa famille.
Si j’ai l’air d’un anglophone maladroit,
(Rires)
Mais aujourd’hui,
je voudrais rêver avec vous d’un futur
où le succès ne signifie pas
l’acquisition de masses d’argent.
Je voudrais rêver avec vous d’un futur
où le succès signifie donner son argent
pour aider les moins fortunés.
Et je voudrais vous montrer
un mécanisme qu’on peut utiliser
pour réaliser ses rêves.
Et je ne parle pas d’une augmentation des
impôts ou d’un salaire minimum plus élevé.
Je parle du mécanisme psychologique
qu’on peut utiliser
pour inciter les membres
plus riches de la société
à faire volontairement des dons
à des organisations caritatives.
Et à la place de se plaindre
ou de fuir le pays,
les riches comprendront l’utilité
de donner leur argent.
Mais pour comprendre comment fonctionnent
ces mécanismes psychologiques,
on doit remonter dans l’Histoire.
Et on va -
On va commencer avec moi
quand j’avais seize ans.
Je n’avais pas d’argent.
Mon père a été arrêté sept fois
par la police avant mes treize ans.
Il n’y a ni cuisine, ni eau chaude
et on avait des escargots
qui rampaient sur nos tapis.
Mais pas les escargots qu’on mange
avec du beurre et de l’ail.
C'était horrible.
Donc, comme beaucoup des personnes
dans la même situation,
je croyais que la réponse
à tous mes problèmes était l’argent.
Donc j’ai créé une série d’entreprises
et très rapidement je pouvais me permettre
de louer un bel appartement
dans le centre de Londres, sans escargots.
Je suis devenu plus heureux.
Mais ensuite, j’ai vu
tout le monde autour de moi
avec des vêtements de marque,
des montres Rolex, des Tesla rouges.
Alors j’ai commencé à travailler
plus dur, plus longtemps
pour acheter ces objets inutiles.
A un moment, j’avais une garde-robe
remplie de polos Ralph Lauren,
de [vestes] Zegna
et de manteaux Hugo Boss.
Mais cette fois,
ces dépenses supplémentaires
ne m’ont pas rendu plus heureux.
Bien sûr que non !
Pourquoi un petit bonhomme sur un poney
me rendrait plus heureux ?
C'était ridicule.
Mais pour acheter ces objets inutiles,
je devais travailler
plus dur, plus longtemps,
j’étais stressé et j’avais
moins de vie sociale.
Mais il ne s'agit pas seulement
d'une anecdote personnelle.
Des études montrent
qu’après 60 000€ de salaire annuel,
plus d’argent a très peu d’effet
positif sur votre bonheur.
Au contraire, plus d’argent
peut avoir l’effet inverse
en nuisant à votre santé mentale,
parce que vous travaillez
plus dur et plus longtemps
pour acheter ces objets inutiles.
Pourquoi tout le monde
veut être millionnaire
quand 60 000€ suffisent pour avoir
une vie confortable et heureuse ?
La réponse, c'est le jeu du statut social.
Si l’argent ne contribue pas
à votre bonheur,
en revanche, il vous permet
d’augmenter votre statut social.
Imaginez par exemple
le millionnaire puissant au statut élevé
contre le sans-abri au statut inférieur.
Dans notre cerveau,
il y a un indicateur de statut social
qui mesure tout le temps notre statut
par rapport à celui des autres.
Après avoir satisfait nos besoins
fondamentaux - eau, nourriture, abri -
tout ce qui intéresse notre cerveau,
c’est notre statut social.
Et pour améliorer notre statut social,
on joue à des jeux de statut.
Les likes Instagram, faire du sport,
acheter des Rolex.
Ce sont des manières
d’augmenter notre statut social,
et pour de très bonnes raisons évolutives.
Il y a de nombreuses espèces animales
qui jouent à des jeux de statut
pour attirer les partenaires sexuels.
Les otaries se battent à mort
pour impressionner les femelles.
Les paons exhibent
leur magnifique plumage.
Les humains ne sont pas différents,
mais nos jeux de statut sont adaptatifs.
Nos jeux de statut évoluent
avec notre environnement.
Par exemple, les premières sculptures
des premiers hommes des cavernes
montrent qu’il préféraient
les femmes plus grosses.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’elles pouvaient survivre
plus longtemps sans nourriture.
Donc à la place de rivaliser
pour avoir la taille plus fine,
elles rivalisaient pour avoir
la taille la plus large.
C’est la même chose avec les hommes.
À la place de suivre un régime pour avoir
des abdos, les rois dans l’antiquité
portaient un rembourrage supplémentaire
pour avoir le plus gros bide.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que cela montrait
qu’ils pouvaient se permettre
beaucoup de nourriture.
Dans la Grèce antique,
avoir un plus petit pénis était considéré
comme plus esthétique,
donc les hommes se battaient
pour savoir qui avait le plus petit pénis
et pas le plus gros.
Il y a 100 ans, avoir la peau plus pâle
était considéré plus sexy.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que cela signifiait
que vous pouviez vous permettre
de rester à l’intérieur à la place
de travailler dehors manuellement.
Donc les femmes utilisaient
des produits blanchissants
pour rendre leur peau plus blanche.
Mais aujourd'hui, c'est l'inverse.
Avoir la peau plus bronzée
est considéré plus sexy,
parce que ça montre que vous pouvez
vous permettre des vacances.
Donc les femmes, et aussi les hommes,
rivalisent avec des produits
de bronzage et de maquillage.
A l’école, les élèves rivalisent
pour obtenir les meilleures notes
en étudiant des matières
qu’ils n’utiliseront plus jamais
pour accéder à une université
plus prestigieuse.
De plus, au travail, des études montrent
que les employés sont prêts à sacrifier
10 000 $ de salaire annuel
pour avoir un poste plus prestigieux
mais moins bien payé.
Et sur ce dernier point,
vous pouvez peut-être voir comment
on peut utiliser les jeux de statut
pour changer radicalement
le comportement social.
Les gens sont prêts à échanger
de l’argent contre un statut.
Par conséquent, il suffit
de créer les bonnes incitations.
Par exemple, à la place
de la liste Forbes des riches,
on crée la liste Forbes de l’impact social
pour classer les personnes
qui donnent le plus pour aider le monde.
Les riches rivaliseront
pour donner leur argent.
Imaginez qu’on enseigne aux enfants
que la définition du succès,
c’est d’aider les autres et de donner
à des organisations caritatives
à la place de courir après une Ferrari
ou une grande maison.
Maintenant, les riches comme Depardieu
font tout pour payer moins d’impôts.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’ils sont jugés pour leur argent
et les gouvernements essaient
de les taxer le plus possible.
Ils n’ont pas de bonne raison
de payer des impôts élevés.
Mais imaginez si on célébrait
les contribuables qui paient le plus.
Imaginez si on les valorisait
comme on valorise un héros.
Oui, idéalement,
les riches paieraient
équitablement les impôts.
Mais [ça ne marche pas comme ça]
où on habite :
les riches sont égoïstes.
Donc on doit leur donner
une bonne raison de payer autant.
Les jeux de statuts changent
tout le temps.
Au siècle dernier, on jouait
à avoir le plus d’argent possible.
Mais on peut changer la règle du jeu.
Peut-être qu’on peut maintenant jouer
à donner la plus d’argent possible.
(Anglais)
Merci beaucoup de votre attention.
(Applaudissements)
(Anglais) Passez une excellente soirée
et excusez mon français.